Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
un gusto saludarles desde París para un
nuevo número de nuestro programa
cultural en el que hacemos un repaso de
los mejores momentos y entrevistas que
hicimos en el 2022
Francia festejó los 200 años del
desciframiento de los jeroglíficos por
johnso a John pollion en este programa
les contaremos esta increíble historia
el premio Nobel de literatura tiene
nombre de mujer la francesa annia no fue
galardonada con la máxima distinción de
las letras mundiales por su obra sobre
la intimidad femenina
recordaremos a Frida Kahlo y su huella
no solo en el arte plástico sino en la
moda como subraya una colorida
exposición presentada en París Y en este
programa las figuras que marcaron el
mundo del cine y del teatro y los
artistas que nos hicieron vibrar con sus
canciones
[Música]
Francia conmemoró por todo lo alto en
2022 a dos grandes de la literatura el
padre del teatro y de la comedia
francesa moliá fue recordado en el 400
aniversario de su nacimiento y el genial
Max el Push el autor de la novela Río en
busca del tiempo perdido recibió
homenajes tras 200 años de su muerte dos
siglos nos separan también del
desciframiento de los jeroglíficos
egipcios y fue gracias a un estudioso
francés quien dedicó una buena parte de
su vida a estudiar esta escritura con
más de 3000 años de antigüedad les
contamos la historia de Johnson
la escritura de los antiguos egipcios
fue durante siglos un Enigma
impenetrable solo un hombre logró
desentrañar el misterio el francés John
pullión un joven erudito y políglota
quien se sirvió de diversos
conocimientos para comprender la
escritura y la civilización egipcias
[Música]
trabajó durante 15 años estudió
numerosas lenguas antiguas y de su época
el árabe el hebreo el copto también el
Coto era muy importante porque era la
última evolución de la lengua y de la
escritura de los antiguos egipcios
hablaba 15 lenguas toda la dificultad de
la escritura egipcias es que los
jeroglíficos son a la vez fonéticos y
simbólicos en la época de shmporio no lo
sabían según Jean los egipcios Tenían un
sistema de escritura complejo que podía
leerse en líneas o columnas de derecha a
izquierda o de izquierda a derecha y sin
vocales además variaba según el objetivo
del texto utilizaban
varias escrituras una escritura
jeroglífica
para los textos sagrados
religioso funerario real y otra
escritura
simplificada cursiva que llamamos y
aráctico o demótico Y
esa escritura es para los textos
profanos como los textos de la
administración y con el método de
Champion podemos leer todas las
escrituras
con el desciframiento de los
jeroglíficos John pollion creó una nueva
ciencia la egiptología y todo eso sin
pisar Egipto años después cuando pudo
viajar a la tierra de los faraones hizo
otro descubrimiento tan sorprendente
como incómodo la creencia en un paraíso
y un infierno o la idea de un Dios
Osiris que resucitó tras un martirio
creencias 3000 años antes del nacimiento
de Cristo
cuando visitó la tumba de se chicha el
padre de Ramsés 2 descubrió que los
antiguos egipcios tenían las mismas
preocupaciones que nosotros y sobre todo
una interioridad sobre los textos
religiosos de la iglesia cristiana Y eso
era un problema
porque en la época había una
verdad que era la verdad de la iglesia
y otra verdad no era posible es por eso
que sabemos que esta información se la
guardó para él
[Música]
el 2022 fue un año extraordinario para
las letras francesas una escritora
francesa fue galardonada con el premio
supremo el Nobel de literatura es la
autora de novelas esencialmente
autobiográficas como los armarios vacíos
memoria de chica el evento o su último
libro El hombre joven fue distinguida
con el Nobel por el coraje y la agudeza
clínica de su escritura pero sobre todo
por defender la libertad de las mujeres
de decidir sobre su cuerpo y sobre sus
vidas escuchemos
pude realizar algo que me apasionó desde
mis 20 años tuve la Gran suerte de haber
podido hacerlo y hoy es cierto que
siento una nueva responsabilidad
Lucharé hasta mi último respiro para que
las mujeres puedan escoger ser madres o
no la contracepción y el derecho al
aborto son la matriz de la libertad de
las mujeres
y este año también la capital francesa
celebró la influencia de la mexicana
Frida Kahlo en la moda a través de una
vasta exposición en el Palé galiera
Frida Kahlo Más allá de las apariencias
reunió objetos que le pertenecieron al
artista y piezas de las casas de moda
que se inspiraron en su figura nos lo
cuentan las responsables de esta
exposición Circe en estrosa y miren
arsalles
para nosotras Bueno ella siempre ha
estado muy adelantada su tiempo o sea de
hecho ella es relevante hoy y también
los temas que pintaba se pintaba con los
corsettes descubiertos hablaba de de sus
diferencias corporales Te pinta sus
autorretratos portando sus sus vestidos
de tehuana Entonces esta exposición
reúne por primera vez todos sus objetos
personales Sí pero también
sus retratos y sus fotografías que nos
dan una lectura más rica porque muestran
como todos estos materiales contribuyan
a este proceso creativo de lo que es hoy
Frida Kahlo bueno nosotros siendo un
museo dedicado a la moda pues nos ha
parecido que no era ningún caso menor
sino muy importante Hasta qué punto ella
inspira y sigue inspirando a la creación
de moda contemporánea que lo hace de
formas muy diferentes hay una forma pues
vamos a decir que se queda en la
estética no está esta estética que
transmite tanta alegría felicidad como
sobre todo alegría de vivir No esas
flores esas Bueno pues que es que es
realmente una estética muy fuerte y muy
inspiradora el papel que los corsés
tienen en esa relación con su cuerpo
como el corsé se convierte en una
segunda piel como se convierte casi en
una prenda y cómo se convierte también
en una obra de arte no Entonces es
infinita Frida
y en Carrusel de las artes les hablamos
todo el año de la producción
cinematográfica francesa y
latinoamericana y fuimos a numerosos
festivales pero tres artistas nos
sorprendieron particularmente con sus
obras nos lo cuenta Melissa barra
el festival de cannes se clausuró este
año con el grito del sueco Rubén quien
se llevó la palma de oro a la mejor
película por sadness comedia irreverente
sobre el mundo de la moda las redes
sociales y las diferencias de clase
dos estatuillas en los festivales de San
Sebastián y biarritz para la colombiana
Los reyes del mundo una cinta con mucho
de realismo mágico sobre cinco chicos de
la calle que aspiran vivir en un paraíso
perdido la directora Laura Mora explora
aquí la violencia de la sociedad
colombiana para mí definitivamente el
arte en general El buen arte Debería ser
político y con eso no quiero decir
militante y a mí me atraviesa mucho la
obsesión sobre la justicia desde esos
premios son una posibilidad de que se
vea la película de que la película pueda
viajar más y pueda tener un diálogo más
amplio con el público en el mundo
[Música]
kiril cerebrenicofartista opositor y
enemigo acérrimo de Putin estuvo dos
veces en Francia pasó por la alfombra
roja de cannes con la esposa de
tchaikovsky y el festival de teatro de
Aviñón le abrió las puertas para
presentar el monje negro y protestar
contra la guerra en Ucrania
queremos terminar la pieza aquí en
Aviñón haciendo un nuevo llamado a parar
la guerra en Ucrania recordar a la gente
que en estos momentos en los que
asistimos al teatro hay Gente muriendo
bajo las bombas
[Música]
y para terminar con broche de oro este
resumen del 2022 Natalia Olivares nos
presenta ahora los mejores momentos de
La Crónica musical o la Natalia Hola
María Carolina y esas aventuras
musicales me llevaron a descubrir una
serie de artistas de todos colores e
incluso a latinoamericanos
he nombrado a Jorge drexler que se ha
ganado últimamente siete premios en los
latinos en Los Grammys Latinos y nos
habló de su último álbum tinta y tiempo
que recibió uno de esos premios tu
corazón
[Música]
siempre contracorriente
la tinta y el tiempo junto con la Hoja
en blanco son los tres ingredientes para
la escritura
quizás el más importante es el tiempo de
los tres para mí no escribir es un acto
de fe y un acto de paciencia es
uno se enfrenta la Hoja en blanco y es
una batalla que pierde casi todas las
veces de hecho la portada del disco es
una hoja en blanco y en la pandemia
particularmente fue muy difícil y a mí
me costó mucho escribir en aislamiento
entonces
me repetía a mí todo el tiempo y de ahí
viene esa canción tranquilo tinta y
tiempo no como que las cosas lo que
tenga que ser escrito será escrito
tocarte
tocarte tocar Jorge drex era el
destacado que conocí en el festival de
tu luz río loco bueno Natalia Yo creo
que un autor importante y que no para de
renovar si Buscar nuevas experiencias es
el francés action Ash Que es poeta
pianista y muchas otras cosas
multifacético que conocí en un momento
importante porque era el momento de su
concierto Sinfónico Sinfónico toda su
obra todo su repertorio acompañado de la
orquesta filarmónica de radio
[Música]
yo pienso que lo que más desprende
fuerza musical es una orquesta sinfónica
fuerza y también ternura porque puede
ser tan potente como suave y hemos hecho
una adaptación de mis canciones para una
orquesta sinfónica con cuerdas y con
todos sus colores sus espacios
[Música]
bueno Natalie no queremos terminar este
programa sin nombrar a un artista que
conociste este año tres que nos
sorprendió con su feminismo con la
fuerza de su mensaje y vamos a terminar
este programa con su canción yellows
para despedirnos desde este 2022
agradeciéndoles muchísimo por habernos
acompañado todo este año y esperando que
nos acompañen en el 2023 Hasta pronto
[Música]